oh never gonna let you down you're
walking talking cheap box baby so what
about spam with me joshing haste and
today we're joined by two absolute
beauty queens cartoon feed which or how
are you great and we're here talk about
very important issues say cyberbullying
because you are fronting that I will not
be deleted campaign Reynolds new
campaign is trying to eradicate
cyberbullying one of the crazy facts I
found out is a hundred and fifty million
Instagram posts a year deleted due to
cyber bullying yes what a lot what are
the biggest precautions you guys have
taken to prevent yourselves being
attacked by cyber bullies but thing
about precautions aren't really any any
picture you put out you're kind of
opening and opening yourself up to being
having people having opinions people
hate saying people saying things and
getting hurt and what we're here to do
is to kind of try and stop that and talk
about it raise awareness we both have
like experienced cyber bullying on
certain degrees and I think that it's
vital to spread the message that it's a
real thing in use ie cyber bullying
people doing things to themselves
because of bullying it's just like
uncalled for it's like we're in 2018 and
I think that the more individual that
you are the better is yeah and I just
think for a makeup brand to be doing
something like this is so incredible
yeah because again that you know makeup
it's something that we shouldn't have to
hide behind you know press ourselves
yeah so when you guys have ever had
knocks of confidence
what kind of like p.m. a mantra have you
told yourself to take yourself back up
again it's really a lot to do with my
friends and like my family and you know
for example whenever I go through
something car has actually been first
handed there to really support me as I
have done with her also and I think that
like it's really good cuz we really
actually genuinely have been through it
so it's almost like seeing that
relations whoever's watching this
interview whether you're 14 or 49 yeah
it happens to everybody and it's
important to be able to like if you
can't take us
to pick up your friend yes yes yes so
many times I'll see a picture reet or
whatever no home and open up God she
looks coarse know what say anything yeah
then instead of doing that reach out to
the person just who it is yeah a friend
when Instagram you know reach out and
say you look running yeah and then it
gives people that because I know
everyone needs validation at some point
violations are really interesting
concept now because I think a lot of
people seek validation online rather
than real life so with the topic of
validation do you think it has to start
from within would you say everything
that you do mmm
you represent yourself and you have to
honestly just like look at what we do
for example in the entertainment story
being in the public eye some people
think that we kind of don't feel the
same as I don't know a regular kind of
like life but we do actually sometimes
because war and everybody needs that
sense of you know support and security
it's not just about young girls and guys
who suffering from this it goes through
whole walks of life now so if you were
saying to someone right now he was
probably like sat in an office and
they're being bullied by one their
co-workers and they're taking that home
with them as well and they're doing
online what would you say to those
people my anger just came out there for
a second I was like who do you think you
are but that's just my what a react so
today yeah how do you stop yourself from
also reacting but also reacting in a bad
way you know part of the reason why I
like you're doing this is to stop not
just the side of the people being buddy
but also buddies as well yeah big
believe and also people that don't stand
up for each other you never really know
what someone is going through and so you
don't want to attack somebody you don't
really know what's happening on everyday
life behind this photograph and I think
that is a real passion for the both of
us to just really have that kind of
sense of like strength is having a
strong sisterhood a way that you keep
grounded and you deal with these
negative things like oh my god I think
for us as well we're surrounded by
yes people do all the time yeah one of
the first people to tell each other are
you all right babe yeah no can you check
your own each other now Michael I would
say a long time and we've experienced
things together as we were growing up in
this industry I'm just so happy that i
had somebody that was like just as cool
and as like solid as i was to kind of be
like don't worry babes we're gonna do
this together and like we really did
create a little like a sister anyway so
important that we all lift each other up
rather than trying to tear each other
down be like that interlude for some
reason I always sing a song that like
relates to the situation I do don't I
like a moment like this you're walking
talking cheap box very so and just get
it going what would you say is the
weirdest or most awful thing you've read
about yourself online well I feel like
an imminent as well journalism is always
quite a lot about telling people you
know things like ugly you know I always
go cooled by looking like a teenage boy
which I was find funny kind of true
someone should I'm fine with that when
it's more about you know your family or
friends or people like that's hard I
mean yeah yeah I think it's probably
easier to do anything else it's like
well I can't change how I got yeah I
post a lot of pictures of my body and
some some people are kind of like what's
happening she's got it she's got a bomb
but it's kind of like yeah I do and this
is also a really real thing to talk
about and it's also a very normal thing
to do yes and I think that's what people
are forgetting it's like hello so I
really try and exaggerate that part of
the woman body yeah that's for me like
really important you raise a really
amazing point about the media treatment
of women so what would you want to see
happen to the media to probably
eradicate this environment that then
enables people to come cyberbullies
creating a world where women all
and people have to miss it against each
other yeah they just love the rise in a
fall they don't like your eyes a night
for yeah money so right I wish people
now would like the rise we like the rise
look sometimes the rise I can with its
also I wish that the public likes that
yes how has beauty and makeup giving you
an inner confidence when you may have
doubt yourself oh my goodness I can't
tell you the amount of times I felt like
a different person
after I put my face on and I might put
my look on I don't know because I write
for me in my job and with my music I
really do take on a full character it's
my way of completely you know expressing
myself it's an art form really being
able to you know have fun with your
friends and feel good about yourself and
try new things out and experiment with
colors and it just shows how we can all
be a chameleon or we can all change and
adapt and feel different and it's also a
nice way to be able to connect with you
mm-hmm
I think we should celebrate everyone
expressing themselves as best they can
on social media so guys get behind this
campaign yes thank you guys for joining
thank you we will not be deleted yes we
will not be deleted please field yes
[Music]